Narrator: For over a decade,
"Shark Tank" has been
at the forefront of innovation.
Our product
brings light to the world.
Bethencourt:
I was fascinated by the idea
of creating an entirely
new type of pet food.
R. Riveter is about
redefining the boundaries
of American
manufacturing.
Narrator: Showcasing America's
most ingenious products
and trend‐setting ideas.
‐There you go.
‐[ Laughter ]
Narrator: Just when you think
you've seen it all,
there's always something new
coming in the Tank.
Which of these companies
will be the next big idea?
The future starts now.
It's alive!
Herjavec: Wow!
♪♪
Narrator: First in the Tank
is a unique way
to remember your loved ones.
♪♪
Hi, I'm Adelle.
And I'm Garrett.
We're from Austin, Texas,
and our company is Eterneva.
Eterneva provides
a soulful solution
to remembering our loved ones
in a positive way.
So, what we do
is grow real diamonds
from the carbon
in someone's ashes.
‐Oh!
‐What?
Hmm?
But really,
we're in the business
of celebrating
remarkable people.
Herjavec: Wow.
We're asking
for $600,000
in exchange
for 5% of our company.
‐Wow.
‐Whoa!
Let us show you
how this works.
This is about
a remarkable person,
someone full of hope
and joy.
We lost our beautiful Katie
in a car accident.
By transforming their ashes
into a diamond,
you can celebrate
that special person.
Now I can say,
"This is my daughter.
This is how beautiful
she really was."
Our diamonds give you
something positive
to look forward to.
At Eterneva,
we turn ashes to diamonds,
but really, we're eternalizing
remarkable people,
and this is how
you'll take them with you
on the rest
of life's adventures.
Wow.
I don't know what to think.
So, we'd like to show you
how it works.
So, this is
our welcome kit.
This is how
we start the process.
This is how somebody
will select their diamond,
and then their ashes
will come back in this kit.
It has be a cremation,
obviously,
or can you take
a piece of somebody
out of a coffin
and then ‐‐
Oh, God, Ke‐‐
I'm asking!
[ Laughter ]
So, how it works
is that we extract carbon
from 1/2 cup of ashes
or hair.
Or hair.
Archer: Correct.
I had no idea.
Once we have carbon
from either ashes or hair,
we then use high pressure,
high temperature
to grow a raw diamond.
Can we see it?
‐Yeah, here's our kit.
‐So, here's the kit.
This is how
you get started.
Yep.
Herjavec: And so what do I do
with this kit, then?
Yeah.
It's about
1/2 cup of ashes
that you put
into the kit.
Greiner: 1/2 cup?
‐A little scoop.
‐So, I take the ashes...
‐Yep.
‐[ Laughs ]
...I throw them
in here...
Cuban: Oh, Lord.
....and I courier this
back to you.
That's right. Absolutely.
Cuban: "Excuse me, Mom.
Give me the scooper."
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec:
So, once you get it,
what do you do with it,
then?
So, first, we're purifying
the ashes into carbon.
And how do you
purify it?
Um,
it's a high‐heat process.
And then we go to growth.
We have machines that are
high‐pressure, high‐temperature.
How big are those machines?
Large refrigerator.
Yeah.
What's the capital cost
of a machine?
It will range.
It'll be between
$50,000 to $180,000.
When do I pay you?
Up front.
Yeah, up front, in full.
Smart.
Our prices range from
$3,000 to $20,000.
Okay.
Our average order value
is $8,000.
What does it cost you
to make that?
It'll be between, like,
$3,000 to $5,000.
How long from me sending you
the ashes or the hair
to me getting
the diamond back?
The end‐to‐end journey
takes about 10 months,
which seems like
a long time ‐‐
‐10 months?
‐Seems like a long time.
However, what we've done
is we've created
a grief‐changing journey
around this process.
So, you know, actually,
how we got into this,
Garrett and I originally
were just starting
a regular lab‐grown
diamond company.
We saw this as
a super up‐and‐coming market,
you know, a lot of Millennials
are doing it.
And, so, we were
starting this company,
and then, uh,
around that time,
my business mentor
and one of my closest friends,
her name's Tracey Kaufman,
got diagnosed
with pancreatic cancer,
and within three months,
passed away.
Oh. Sorry.
And... [ Sighs ]
She didn't have any kids,
she didn't have a husband,
and so, um, the people
that she mentored, like me,
were effectively
her family.
And so that was actually
one of her wishes
was that each of us would get
a little bit of her ashes
and that we were allowed to do
something really meaningful
and really celebratory
for her.
That's sweet.
Oh, that's great.
Archer:
So, as a full customer,
I went to go
start this process
not, you know, thinking about,
"Oh, let's do this business,"
and I actually was
very turned off by
the experience.
It was really
transactional.
You know,
they were really cold.
And so I just
didn't feel comfortable
sending Tracey to them.
And so that was really
when Garrett and I
kind of came back,
and we put our business hats on,
and we said,
"Okay, customer experience
is everything,
and we know
how to do that.
You know,
we really could do this."
So, that's when we pivoted,
and now we're doing
3 1/2 times the volume
of all of our competitors
in a year and a half.
What about pets?
Pets is
a massive market.
Huh.
What are your sales?
So, our first year in sales,
we did $913,000.
Wow.
And we're projecting to do
$2.7 million this year.
And did you raise
any outside money?
Yeah, we raised
around $1.2 million round
at a $10 million
valuation.
Ohh, damn.
O'Leary: How much?
God, I loved the story
until that point.
Archer: So, we actually have
unbelievable investors.
They are all entrepreneurs
who have had
$200 million‐plus exits.
Yeah, but that's
not even the point.
So, we wanted
strategic money
that joined
our cap table.
Guys, you come on here,
right,
knowing you're going
to have to negotiate,
but that puts a cap on what
you're able to negotiate.
O'Leary:
There's nothing proprietary
about what you're doing.
You're just very good
at how you package it up
and marketing it.
But frankly,
I could do this myself.
I can buy four machines
and bang out cat diamonds,
no problem.
See, that's the thing,
though,
is that's what
our competitors did,
and they fell
flat on their face.
John:
I'm a little skeptical,
and I think that
you have investors
that all have
$200 million exits.
Tens of thousands of people
apply to stand on this rug,
and every person
that takes this carpet
that has the money,
then they took
a chance away
from somebody
who desperately needed help.
♪♪
Do you understand where
I'm seeing this as a problem?
What he's asking you is
are you happy
with the commercial
that we're making for you
right now?
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but Daymond and Mark
are concerned
that Adelle and Garrett
might not need an investment
for their diamonds‐from‐ashes
company, Eterneva.
John: Do you understand
where I'm seeing this
as a problem?
Cuban:
What he's asking you is
are you happy
with the commercial
that we're making for you
right now?
Archer: No.
I mean, seriously, guys,
our investors
are wonderful.
They're tech investors.
They aren't the people
who can help.
This is a household, you know,
branded experience,
and we need partners
that can help us
get in front of consumers
and introduce us to ‐‐
Yeah.
But you already have
so much at your disposal.
I just don't see it.
I'm out.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Greiner:
Let me jump in for a minute.
There's just
something for me about this
that just doesn't feel good
to me.
It doesn't feel right.
Um, so, I'm sorry, I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
I appreciate it.
Cuban: Guys, look,
I love the idea.
You're a celebration company.
Whether it's death,
whether it's human,
whether it's pet,
whether it's birth,
I would've loved
to take a hair from my kids
when they were born
and put it in, you know,
a diamond
and give it to my wife
as a gift,
even if it took 10 months.
I actually love
what you're doing.
What I can't get my arms around
is how serious you are
about one of us
as an investor.
We're here to negotiate,
Mark.
Okay.
We would love to have you
on our team.
Well, then,
I'll make you an offer.
Mm‐hmm.
$600,000 for 15%.
♪♪
Would you be willing
to come up
to a $10 million
valuation?
Can't go lower than $10 million,
just with the nature of it.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You're proving my point
about why you're here.
You know?
No, I mean, we would love
to have you guys.
Herjavec: I understand
what Mark is saying,
and he may be right.
It's a great business,
but I hate the fact that
you have the other investors
and yet you're here.
So, all I can speak to that with
is my offer.
Mm.
Because if you value us,
you've got to pay a premium
for that.
So, I'll give you
the $600,000 for 10%.
It's half the valuation
you're asking for,
but I think we bring
twice the value.
O'Leary:
I also have an offer.
I'll do it for 12%.
$600,000 for 12%.
♪♪
15%, 12%, 10%.
Greiner: 10%.
Robert and Mark,
would you guys
be willing to go in
at $500,000 for 5% each?
You're walking your line
at, you know ‐‐
Your valuation from
your previous investors
is driving
your negotiation.
Herjavec:
Mark's a great guy.
I have no problem
with having him
as part as the deal if he wants
to be a part of the deal,
but I have to have
a better valuation.
Yeah.
Mark's initial point,
the only place
your pitch fell apart
is when you told us
about the investors.
Kind of just ‐‐
you went right off the cliff.
So, if you want a Shark,
pay a premium.
♪♪
$500,000 for 5% each,
but with 1% advisory shares
for each of you guys.
Herjavec: Uh,
it doesn't work for me.
I think you just
made the point.
I don't think you were here
to get a deal.
♪♪
I'm out.
Mark?
Got to do better,
'cause I know
I can help you do better.
I'm not
your other investors.
♪♪
Is there something
in between?
I'll listen,
but you have to decide.
Give him another offer.
It's your deal to lose.
So, was it the 1% ‐‐
Okay, I'm gonna buy
my own machines. I'm out.
♪♪
Okay.
Um, would you meet us
at an $8 million valuation
with the 1% advisory?
So, $600K for 7.5%?
Come on, Mark.
[ Chuckles ]
If you give me ‐‐
Yeah, if you give me
the $600K for 9%,
I'll do it.
And that might mean
each of you giving up 1 point.
1% from each one of you,
the 1% advisory shares,
the 6% for the $600,000,
that gets you there.
♪♪
Yeah?
Let's do it.
Yes.
Archer: [ Laughs ]
I knew you guys
were smart.
Cuban: [ Laughs ]
Congratulations, man.
‐Awesome.
‐Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Appreciate it.
It was impressive.
Archer: Now that Mark
is part of the team,
the sky
is the absolute limit
because we need people
behind us
that are helping us
make this an option
that absolutely
every person knows about
and don't regret not knowing
that this was an option,
and he's gonna get us there,
so we're so grateful.
♪♪
Narrator:
In previous seasons,
Mark Cuban invested
in two businesses
that helped students.
We have an average
SAT score improvement
that's industry‐leading.
The digital change
from your everyday purchases
can help pay off
American student debt.
Narrator: Let's see
how they're doing now.
‐Hi, welcome.
‐Thanks for coming.
Patel:
We're here for this amazing
event called Tuition Paid
where Prep Expert and ChangEd
are collaborating
to teach high school
and college students
how to pay off college tuition
as effectively as possible.
Give it up
for Mark Cuban.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Cuban: 44 million people
have student debt
in this country
totaling more
than $1.5 trillion ‐‐
that's a "T" ‐‐
trillion dollars.
Any time we can give students
the best tools for success,
I want to be part of it.
The best return on investment
that you can have,
improving your test scores
to win scholarships.
Patel: The year that
I pitched on "Shark Tank,"
we had done $600,000
in sales.
3 1/2 years later,
we've done over
$20 million in sales.
Set it up once and let this run
in the background.
We round up
the spare change
and send it towards
your student loans
automatically.
When we pitched
on "Shark Tank,"
we only had
800 customers.
Today, we have
over 30,000 users.
30,000 users
means that we're now managing
over $1 billion
in student loan debt on ChangEd.
Cuban: The number‐one rule
right now is,
what's a school
you can afford?
If you can't go
to a major university to start,
go to a community college
first.
Patel: Today, Mark showed us
he's not just our investor,
he's also our partner.
Solving the student loan
debt crisis
is just as important to him
as it is to Prep Expert
and ChangEd.
Thank you, Vegas.
You guys are great.
I'll be here all week.
[ Laughs ]
The day I paid off
my student loans
was one of the happiest days
of my life.
Student loan debt
is an incredible burden
not just on the students
that owe that money,
but on the entire economy.
With ChangEd and Prep Expert,
we can change that,
and I'm excited
for the impact they can have
on the entire country.
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a fashion item
that is as functional
as it is stylish.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks,
my name is Brandon.
And my name
is Marcellus.
And we're asking for
$150,000
in exchange for 10%
of our company, Baobab.
We are two hardworking
professionals
living in New York City
who just love to wear
polo shirts.
It's almost like
our uniform.
But we got tired and frustrated
with how they failed us
after only a few wears
and washes.
And you guys know exactly
what he's talking about.
When your shirt fades...
And goes from
classy to ashy.
Or when it shrinks up
in the wash.
And your large
turns into a shmedium.
Oh, my God,
I hate shmediums!
[ Light laughter ]
Or when your collar
bacons and curls,
that's something
that we call bacon collar.
So we set out
on a mission
to solve all these problems
and more
through using design,
technology, and innovation.
And that's why we created
the Baobab polo shirt...
The perfect polo shirt!
...the perfect polo shirt!
The Baobab polo shirt
is made from the best cotton
in the world ‐‐
Peruvian Pima cotton.
Now, through our proprietary
fabrication process
called BaoTech,
it makes this shirt
completely resistant to stains,
like coffee?
Coming right up.
‐Wow.
‐Whoa
‐Like wine.
Did you order Pinot Noir?
I did, I did.
‐Wow.
‐Dang.
Cuban: Not the ketchup!
No!
Davenport:
I used to always hate
when something like this
would happen.
[ Laughter ]
Like I said,
not the ketchup!
‐No!
‐Not the ketchup.
Here you go, bro.
Absolutely.
‐Wow.
‐Wow!
Sharks,
when I do decide to wash it,
it's not gonna shrink
or fade.
And with our patent‐pending
stay‐flat collar,
we keep collars looking great
for a really long time.
Sharks,
let's take a bite
out of this $30 billion
menswear industry
and join us in making
undeniably better polo shirts.
All right. Very cool.
Great presentation!
And meanwhile, I want to
make sure that I see you guys,
so I'm gonna go ahead
and clean off my glasses
with this hidden
microfiber cloth
that's on the inside.
Greiner: Oh, you're kidding.
[ Laughs ]
Cuban: [ Laughs ]
But wait, there's more!
Alexander: Just to make sure
we can see each other.
Greiner: That's so smart.
Yeah,
that is a cool idea.
Herjavec: Oh,
the material's great.
Davenport: Nice black polo.
It's the all black.
Thank you.
We have the black polo
for you there.
Greiner:
Oh, and it's a zipper.
O'Leary: So, guys,
is this 100% pure cotton?
So, it's 98%
Peruvian Pima cotton,
and then there's
2% stretch.
And what do you
charge for it?
We charge $98.
What stops the ketchup
from staining the white shirt?
Yeah, so,
that's the BaoTech.
So, it's a treatment
when we produce
the fabric of the shirt
that's added
that protects the shirts.
My biggest pet peeve
with polo shirts is the collars.
‐Yes!
‐The bacon collar.
‐Right.
‐That is such a great idea.
And I'm glad
you brought that up.
We actually have
a provisional patent
on our stay‐flat collar.
Can you tell us
what's your background,
what did you used to do
before this?
And same with you.
Yeah, so,
I worked at a media company.
I did partnerships,
media partnerships ‐‐
Which one?
So, Hearst Media is one of them,
and also Travelzoo.
And, Brandon,
what do you do?
So, I worked at companies
like American Express
managing
their mobile app.
When did you start
this business?
So, we actually did
a crowdfunding campaign
to get the funding
behind the research
and development
back in 2017.
You did a crowdfunding campaign
for the research?
Yes.
How much did you raise?
It was $32,000.
Greiner: That's brilliant.
Well, you had to deliver
a product, right?
Yeah, and we delivered
the product ‐‐
so we pre‐sold shirts
for that.
You're saying
you're worth $1.5 million.
That means
that you must have sold,
within the last year,
$800,000 worth
of product.
And?
So, uh, we've done $85,000
in gross revenue.
‐That's it?
Yeah, because, uh, we're not
VC‐backed or anything.
We had to put our own money
and reinvest into, uh ‐‐
How much of your own money
have you put in?
About $35,000.
Maybe you're not worth
$1.5 million.
No, really?
Well, maybe
you're worth more.
Well, I never get upset
about crazy valuations
'cause I believe in the vision.
We've sold $32,000 worth
of inventory, so...
‐Wow.
‐Oh.
All off of
your website?
A little off
from the $800,000.
Right, but being
digital marketers,
we understand our customer,
we understand the data sets
and where we can go,
and the more we turn up
our digital ads ‐‐
Herjavec: Before we argue
about your valuation...
Yeah.
...I invested in a company
last year called Butter Cloth...
Mm‐hmm.
Okay.
...and we've done
about $3.5 million
worth of sales.
Yeah.
This is fascinating to me.
Tell me how you spent $32,000
to create
a proprietary material.
So, the proprietary element
of the shirt is BaoTech.
But what is that?
Is that a chemical
or is that material?
Shrinking, fading, stains,
and odors ‐‐
It's the process
behind that ‐‐
Anybody can get that.
Anybody can do that, right?
Can anybody do that?
Anybody can do it.
We own the name
behind BaoTech.
You can buy ‐‐
There's a lot of
different technologies
that you can try
to piece together,
different things that ‐‐
So, I want to be
really clear on that.
What you're asking me
to invest in
is you two guys
and the brand.
Yes.
Not in a proprietary
material.
No, no.
Correct.
So, guys, if I go online
and just search polos,
there are thousands
of options.
Zillions.
Sure. Sure.
Okay?
Huge marketplace.
If I go into retail,
there are hundreds of choices
I can make
at different price points
with different brands.
Absolutely.
Some brands,
very well‐known globally.
Then there's...
Bobab, right?
Baobab.
‐Baobab.
That's another problem.
Baobab.
What?
Baobab...
O'Leary: Baobab.
...it's the tree of life
in Africa.
We wanted to pick a name
that represented strength
and longevity ‐‐
How about a name
people can pronounce?
Let's go with that.
Look, guys,
this is a story
about a very special
polo shirt...
It is.
Davenport: Yes.
...in a really
competitive market.
Really competitive.
So, in the last two months,
we've done $35,000 ‐‐
Cuban: So tell us
how you sold ‐‐
That's nothing!
No, wait, so tell us
how you sold $35,000.
To Kevin's point,
you have to communicate that
and translate that
into sales.
Tell us
how you're doing that.
Our cost per acquisition,
our cost per sale is $38.
We sell primarily online.
How are people finding you?
Uh, so, it's on Facebook ads
and Instagram ads, as well.
And we've also gotten
some recent press
for being one of
the best polo shirts
to buy this summer.
There's nothing special
about the shirt
in regards to it can be done
by any and everybody,
but I think that
you've made slight adjustments
to make something
really great,
'cause the shirt
is a great shirt.
But you have a $1.5 million
valuation there.
What is the reasoning
for that?
So, we have
more inventory coming
and we're looking to sell
a lot more
and close the year out
at $400,000.
So, we did a 3 times
multiple of that.
Of what?
Of ‐‐ Of the ‐‐
Of 3 1/2 times ‐‐
Of future sales.
'Cause we're gonna get there
at the end of the year.
I have learned
to not listen to Daymond
and love
the clothing business.
We're doing really well
with Butter Cloth,
and we're about
to introduce a polo,
so it would be
competitive for me.
I'm out.
Okay.
Is this full‐time
for you guys now?
It is full‐time.
Yes.
And you guys are still
based in New York?
‐Yes.
‐We're based in New York City.
How are you living?
Occasionally,
we've, like, paid ourselves,
but nothing serious.
If there's a consulting
opportunity,
we may take that.
What kind of consulting?
So, digital customer
acquisition, generally.
So that's the important part,
right?
I mean,
it's a great product,
but how you sell digitally
makes or breaks this company.
Absolutely.
And what you haven't done
is convinced us
that that's
your secret sauce,
that you guys are experts
in that category.
I'm a tech guy.
Yeah.
Sell me on what you can do
technologically.
So, we're building
community online.
Every customer,
we're reaching out to them,
getting feedback.
Our repeat customer rate
is around 25%.
But how?
Is it just Facebook ads
and then you just stay connected
with them via e‐mail, or...?
Yeah, so, let's not
overcomplicate this.
That's the beauty
about digital, right?
It levels the playing field
for every company.
Right.
And, so,
we're taking the tools
and our knowledge
and experience
and applying it
to our business.
Look, you've done a great job
at explaining the opportunity,
but you have
a pretty hard road ahead
explaining the difference
between this
and all the other
competitors.
I'm not gonna take the journey.
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
You still have other Sharks.
Thank you, though.
John: So, guys, you've come up
with a great product,
but the sales right now,
that's the only hard data
that I can go off of.
Right.
And I'm over here
wrestling with the valuation,
and then I have to just believe
you're a good digital marketer.
Again, I love the shirt,
but I just don't think
it's there for me.
I'm out.
Um, I think you guys
are doing everything right.
Like, you hit every single thing
spot‐on.
You added the repellent
for the stains,
you added the wiping cloth,
which I just love.
Microfiber.
I will definitely
be a customer.
Unfortunately here,
I just don't think that
this is right for me.
For those reasons, I'm out.
Cuban: Guys.
So we ‐‐ So we ‐‐
We're deciding whether ‐‐
Wait. There's one Shark left.
Address Mark Cuban.
Okay, go ahead.
Guys, I tried
to get to the heart
of your digital marketing
skills, right?
Because that's what's gonna
make or break you.
I've been begging
to get it out of you,
and I just haven't
been able to,
and I was looking for it.
I was right there,
closeable,
and you didn't come at me
and close me.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
♪♪
We're done here, guys.
Thank you very much.
Sorry, guys.
Congrats on what
you've accomplished.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you for your time.
‐Good luck. Great shirt.
‐Thanks.
‐Good luck, guys.
‐Good luck.
♪♪
Alexander:
So, I'm gonna say this.
I thought we did
the perfect pitch.
I'm still trying to process
how we didn't get a deal
from having
the perfect polo
and our experience behind
the digital side, as well.
That's kind of how I feel
right now.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a new product
inspired by
an old technology.
♪♪
My name
is Jake Slatnick.
I'm from
San Diego, California.
And my name's
Eric Goodchild,
and I'm from
Phoenix, Arizona.
And we're seeking $500,000
for 7% of our company.
‐Whoa.
‐Wow.
In today's world, everything
needs to be wirelessly charged.
Your phone, your watch,
your headphones ‐‐ everything.
And so an innovative technology
was released
to make the whole process
easier,
something you've probably
heard of ‐‐
wireless charging.
And the consensus?
Ehh.
If your phone's just
slightly off the center,
the thing
doesn't even work.
Well, that doesn't seem
so innovative.
It's not.
So, we've created the future
of wireless charging.
♪♪
[ Sharks yelling ]
It's alive! It's alive!
Bwah! Ha‐ha‐ha‐ha‐ha!
[ Laughing ]
♪♪
That is so cool.
[ Laughter ]
Introducing Aira,
the world's first free‐position
wireless charger.
This is the real future
of wireless charging.
Based on technology
invented by Nikola Tesla
over 100 years ago,
Aira technology wirelessly
charges your phone
and many other devices.
And let's get
one thing straight ‐‐
this is not
a charging pad.
This is
a charging surface.
That means you can place
multiple devices
in any orientation,
and they'll all
receive power.
Let me show you
what I mean.
One phone down,
charging.
Another phone down,
Put a phone in the middle,
also charging.
All three phones are charging
with free position.
This is the first
of its kind.
Put Aira anywhere
you put your phone
and never
run out of power again.
Wire‐free
is the way to be.
Isn't it time
we cut the cord?
So who's ready for the next
era in wireless charging?
Greiner: Wow.
So, do we get samples?
We have one sample
to show you guys.
Eric will hand that out.
Are you shipping product,
or are you just ‐‐
is it still
in prototype mode?
So, we just finished
our production prototype
and we're actually moving
into the production phase.
So, we have one ‐‐
he's gonna pass it down ‐‐
and what
I want to make clear is
there's a cosmetic example
and then the electronics
example.
Herjavec: Which is the...
The cosmetic example
is the one that looks like
a retail product.
Is this what the finished
product would look like?
So ‐‐ Kevin, pay attention
to this one ‐‐
we're actually
a licensing business, right?
So, the electronics module
that you hold in your hand
is what we actually will sell
to our licensees.
So, anybody can then
buy this technology from you,
and they're going to brand it
however they want to?
Exactly.
Alright.
So, the product
in your hand now
is how you might see it
on a retail shelf.
Can it scale larger?
We can make this
in any size.
Like, what about an iPad
and two phones, right?
So, if an iPad was wirelessly
enabled to charge ‐‐
It's coming, though.
Yeah, absolutely.
Herjavec: Jake,
isn't this available today?
Tell me the difference
between this
and my Apple charger.
Perfect.
So, wireless charging
right now
all works
exactly the same.
There's a little coil
in there, actually,
that looks just like this.
There's a little hotspot
in the center of that thing,
and if you're not lined up,
you can't receive power.
And just to give you
a little insight ‐‐
so, Eric is one of the foremost
experts in the world
on Tesla coils.
Wow.
And the same
underlying technology ‐‐
Really?
Yeah, he actually holds
a Guinness Book of World Record
for one of the largest,
most powerful Tesla coils
ever built.
Really?
Yeah.
He's been an expert in this
for over a decade.
The wireless power,
you know,
between this big coil
and the small coil
is the same technology
that's built into phones today.
And, Eric, did you actually
build this?
Yeah, I built this coil
in high school.
It's been rebuilt, like,
five or six times.
Greiner: Oh, my gosh.
You actually built this?
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Yeah, it's hand‐built.
Are you familiar
with uBeam
and what Energous is doing,
as well?
I'm not familiar
with uBeam.
Okay,
they're two competitors.
uBeam's a company
I happen to be an investor in
that doesn't take
the same approach.
It's fully wireless
from any point in a room
to be able to distribute
using sound‐based technology.
Hmm. Interesting.
I still think that
there's a strong chance
you guys get leap‐frogged.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
♪♪
Okay.
Herjavec: Jake, do you have
a final product?
Do you have
any licensing deals?
Do you have any sales?
So, we already have
our first licensing partner.
They're one of the largest
companies in the space.
They put in
their first order last week
for 33,000 pieces.
33,000 pieces?
And what is that retail
equivalent?
So, it's up to our licensees
what it retails for,
but we can say that we'd get
between $4 and $10 per unit.
But they were so excited
about the technology
that they pre‐paid
the royalties
on all 33,000 units.
Wow.
Herjavec: If you've already
been pre‐paid for the license
from the first licensee,
why do you need
the money today?
So, we have
a burn rate right now
of $30,000 a month,
and that needs to go up
to $50,000 a month
in order to bulk up
our engineering team
and get to market
on time.
John: Listen,
I see tech moving so quick,
and I just don't see
the long‐term vision
because things will
constantly change,
so I'm out.
Okay. Understood.
Herjavec: Eric, I think
it's really clever.
This could be
one of those things
that could be world‐changing,
revolutionary technology.
All right, I'll give you
the $500,000 for 10%.
♪♪
‐Oh, man.
‐Oh.
Tell me now.
Greiner: Kevin and I
were just talking,
so I'll tell you now.
This is a tricky space,
right?
But you're very impressive.
Kevin and I are gonna
give you an offer together.
Okay.
So, our offer is $500,000
at 9% interest as a loan.
We want 15% equity.
We're gonna split it
7.5% each.
Ouch.
O'Leary:
But we'll guide you
to the state
you needed on licensing.
We do
a lot of licensing.
You don't need
a line of credit.
Greiner:
So there's a lot of ‐‐
You're trying to build
a business.
Yeah, and we're looking
for a partner.
We're looking for
strategic partners.
Yeah, I'll give you
the $500,000 for 10%.
We'll build this thing together.
This is not the time
to get a loan.
Do you want to change it
from a line of credit ‐‐
Either you believe in this
and you're gonna do it for ‐‐
Oh, we absolutely
believe in it.
We don't need a loan for this.
‐Okay.
$500,000, 10% ‐‐
I think that's a fair offer.
We've changed ours.
‐That's my last offer.
‐We've changed ours.
We're no longer
a line of credit.
We're gonna be
the $500,000,
we're gonna put the money in
as an investment,
but we're still
at the 15%.
You get two Sharks.
Two huge Sharks.
You guys want 15%?
Yeah, because
we're really good.
We do.
Guys, you got two offers.
What do you want to do?
Guys, we're gonna
really work for it.
[ Whispering ]
I think it's what we want.
I think the 10%.
[ Whispering ] Yeah.
Your call.
♪♪
[ Normal voice ]
This is a tough decision.
Um...
Always is.
Good offers are tough.
Um...
♪♪
[ Sighs ]
I've made you an offer
that's fundamentally better ‐‐
Mm‐hmm.
...$500,000 for 10%.
Do you want two Sharks
or not?
You got it this far.
Well?
We can get
to the next level.
Can we get the three of you guys
for 15%?
Interesting.
We'll do that deal
right now.
Greiner: [ Chuckles ]
For $500,000 for 15%?
$500,000 for 15%
if we get the three of you.
♪♪
Done.
Yeah.
[ Normal voice ]
Whoo‐hoo!
Alright.
[ Laughter ]
‐Cool.
‐Good job!
Greiner: I don't know if we've
ever turned our heads like that.
Thank you.
You are very good,
my friend.
Thank you.
Good job.
That was really good.
O'Leary: Are you gonna
light that puppy up?
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐Thanks.
John:
Congratulations, guys.
Goodchild: It was two
really hard choices,
and at the end
of the day,
we turned it into
one really great one.
One great choice.
Absolutely.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a solution
to an age‐old mystery.
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Jessica, Alpha Squid.
And I'm Gabe,
Beta Squid.
And these are our Squid Kids,
Casen and Claire.
We're asking for $125,000
for 20% of our company.
♪♪
Sharks, every day,
thousands go lost, missing,
and unaccounted for.
They've lost their homes,
their families,
their loved ones.
We've all seen them
on the side of the road,
at the park,
at the store.
[ Gasps ]
Baby socks!
‐[ Laughs ]
While these cold cases
may never be solved,
there is a solution
to prevent this problem
from ever happening again.
Herjavec: [ Chuckles ]
Ta‐da.
Sharks, we have reinvented
the baby sock.
Squid Socks have squiddy dots
inside the cuff
that hold socks on.
Casen, you're super strong,
right?
Let's pull
baby Claire's sock off.
Pull her Squid Sock off.
Pull from the toe.
Pull as hard as you can!
You're so strong!
Good job, Casen!
Awesome job, buddy.
High five!
Good job, buddy.
[ Chuckles ]
Whether it's
at the grocery store,
in the car seat, at home,
day care, or anywhere,
the sock battle is a real
problem and pain point.
Babies and toddlers
love to pull their socks off,
and for busy parents,
that extra hassle
is just too much.
Squid Socks helps parents
and caregivers
take back some sanity
and make the daily sock battle
a thing of the past.
So, Sharks, who's ready
to share their ocean
with our little Squids?
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
We have a pull‐test here.
Could we get a Shark
to come...
I'll do it.
Gabe:
...help us with that?
So, Lori, on this side,
we have a traditional
baby sock,
and on this side,
we have a Squid Sock.
If you want to just pull on
both of those socks.
Both at the same time?
Yes.
Oh, wow.
Oh, don't break her leg,
Lori.
[ Laughter ]
Don't hurt the baby!
Jessica: You break her,
you buy her.
Oh, my God.
This is a real baby,
you know.
Honestly, like,
it really stayed.
All right, we're gonna hand out
some samples for you guys
really quick.
Come on, you're gonna
help me, buddy.
Okay,
so this is Robert, okay?
Herjavec: Hi.
You're gonna give Robert
this pack, okay?
Thank you very much.
Say, "There you go, Robert."
Okay, then Robert's gonna
hand these to Lori, okay?
Greiner: Thank you.
Okay.
And then we're gonna
give this to Kevin.
Do you want to stand up there
and give it to Kevin?
Okay,
what do you say to Kevin?
Don't bite me, Kevin.
That's right,
"Don't bite me, Kevin."
[ Laughs ]
Herjavec: Aww.
Good job, buddy.
So, you guys all have
a kitted pack,
and then a loose one
so you can feel that.
Okay, buddy.
Great job, sweetie.
Let's go!
Bye‐bye.
Good job, guys!
Is Jessica coming back?
Absolutely.
[ Laughs ] Ah.
Um, I only like socks
that have
this kind of bottom.
The anti‐slip.
Because, right,
you're gonna slip and fall.
Right.
So it's really smart
you put it on ‐‐
Oh!
...you incorporated the bottom
using that,
but now your ingenuity
is in the inside here...
Correct, that's
the bread and butter.
...where you're putting
your dots.
Yeah. That's right.
So, tell me
how you came up with it.
So, we were on our honeymoon
about 4 1/2 years ago.
We were visiting
his cousin.
And we were sitting down,
eating dinner,
and his little son's socks
kept falling off,
and dad
was so frustrated.
He goes, "Ugh, if somebody
could just invent a sock
that would stay on ‐‐
a baby sock
it'd be
a million‐dollar idea."
We're like,
"Ding ding ding ding!"
[ Laughs ]
Literally that night,
we went back
to our hotel room and...
[Imitates keyboard clacking]
"Does anybody have this?
Really? No?"
That's a honeymoon.
‐That's a honeymoon!
‐Yeah, right?
True entrepreneurs.
"Honey!"
[ Laughter ]
And did you then
seek to patent it?
So, we have
one utility patent pending
on the squiddy dots
inside the cuff,
and then
we have trademarks.
Herjavec: I have
13‐month‐old twins.
Right.
I don't even
put socks on them anymore
'cause they're
gonna be gone.
They're on the side
of the street,
they're in cars,
they're everywhere.
We've had customers that
that pain point is so real,
these are the only socks
that they'll
have their kids wear.
It's brilliant.
The challenge, guys ‐‐
I mean, it says,
"Squiddy dots
hold socks on,"
but how are you gonna
communicate to people,
you know,
that they need this?
Gabe: Right.
One thing we're doing
is introducing a new program
for our retailers
where we have
a video of baby socks,
pulling their socks off ‐‐
That's expensive.
I've been through this
with many other products.
The compliance
at the store level
to actually implement,
install, maintain?
Zero.
Yeah, 'cause no one cares.
Herjavec: Where are you
in the growth of the company?
Are you pre‐launch?
Do you have sales?
Yeah, so, we have been
in business for 16 months.
We have
$40,000 in sales.
$40,000?
♪♪
Kevin,
before you do the whole
"Behind the barn, Old Yeller"
thing here...
I was just warming up
when you brought that up.
[ Laughs ]
Before you go there,
we've had significant
production issues
that have starved us
of inventory repeatedly.
Did you launch
on your website,
or did you go to retail
right away?
We launched
on our website.
So, did anybody
buy it off the website?
We probably sold
$20K worth of product,
but we ran out of inventory,
and then our second batch
had quality issues,
and then we were starved.
Quality was so bad
that we had to reject
the whole thing.
They said, "Sorry, we're not
willing to fix the quality."
Whoa.
So, literally,
we went from nothing,
having no manufacturer,
nothing,
to, in seven months,
finding a new manufacturer,
expanding the product line
from two sizes to four,
from three collections
to 18 collections,
in seven months.
I don't think you told us
what you sell it for.
We retail them for $24
and wholesale them for $12.
And what's it cost you
to make?
$5.85 landed.
For the three‐pack?
Yeah,
for the three‐pack.
You have a patent pending,
you've got a great idea.
Sock industry definitely has
big, established players.
What about going
to a domestic player in socks
and say, "Look, we need you
to actually become partners
with us in this,"
they manufacture
and hold inventory,
and you use
their distribution system, too?
That's the strategy
for this deal,
'cause you got to flood
the market real fast...
Absolutely.
before you get knocked out.
And what do you say,
Jessica?
Have you tried that?
We're open.
I mean, we're not gonna take
that off the table, for sure.
We're still in it.
You know, reinventing
and starting a new sock company
makes practically no sense
because it's
a really old industry,
and the lines of distribution
are already established.
John: Kevin can talk about
you can't reinvent the sock,
but my guys at Bombas
didn't reinvent the sock,
but they're doing
a massive amount of business.
And they're doing
extremely well.
I mean, guys,
I think the path
for success here is obvious,
but, you know,
there's other Sharks
that have companies
in the sock business,
and I don't want
to start from scratch
in the sock business,
and I don't want
to do all the work
to set up the logistics.
What a hassle
that's gonna be.
But, look,
you shouldn't take this
behind the barn and shoot it
'cause it's a great idea.
Thank you.
And you've got
to figure out a way
to get logistics,
but I'm out.
Okay. I respect that.
Thank you.
Thank you
for all your feedback.
Look, I can't disagree
with anything you've said.
It's a great company...
Thank you.
...you've set
a great foundation,
and, you know, one of
the great indicators of success
is your ability
to fight back from problems.
Right.
All those things
that drive you crazy.
The reality is, though,
this is not my wheelhouse.
It's just, you know...
[ Laughs ]
I may be a puppet guy,
but I'm not a sock guy.
So I'm out.
[ Laughs ] Okay.
Thanks, Mark.
You're welcome.
[ Laughs ]
Greiner:
I like everything about it.
I think that
if you buy these,
why would you ever buy
any other sock?
Right.
But, um, I'm not sure
it's the right investment
for me,
so I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you, Lori.
You know,
you're very small,
but you're very committed.
Extremely.
And you're
the nicest two people
I think we've had in the Tank
in a long time.
Aww.
I'm not
in the sock business today,
but I've done very well
in the clothing business.
And what we've learned
out of that is
it's great
to have a great product,
but it's also important
to have a very unique position.
But this stuff
is a lot of work.
It's a lot of work.
Our team can really help you
with the digital marketing...
Yes.
...some of the back end.
Yeah.
We can help you
get out there.
But, uh...
[ Laughs ]
....$125,000
and you're asking for 20%.
Again, I know
the amount of work.
I'll give you the $125,000
for...
40%.
Oh! Hello.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Jessica and Gabe have an offer
on the table from Robert
for their stay‐on
baby‐sock company,
Squid Socks.
I'll give you the $125,000
for...40%.
Oh! Hello.
It's really a flyer
on a great product
and two great people.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate the offer.
Now, Daymond "Sock Man."
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Yeah, I have interest.
I like this.
Yeah, I think that
something like, you know,
you should have somebody doing
the manufacturing and licensing,
and then you have the ability
to sell direct to your customer.
You keep that category.
And I think there's another
licensing play here, as well ‐‐
licensing the technology
to some of
the bigger guys or girls,
for two reasons.
Number one, you take them
out of the market
as potential competitors
trying to make something else,
some other version of yours...
Okay.
...as well as, in this area,
a lot of them already
have the characters
like Peppa Pig and Marvel
and stuff like that.
So, they're selling massive ‐‐
I mean, they're doing
$200 million.
Right.
Mm‐hmm.
I think I can help you.
I'm gonna match
Robert's offer.
[ Sighs ]
O'Leary: Whoa.
John: Are you ‐‐
Yeah, you know what?
I wouldn't want to be
more of an owner
than the owners,
so I will take it down
to 33%.
33%.
Ooh.
$125,000 for 33%.
That's pretty good.
I love it.
33%?
Greiner:
And you know what?
I like Daymond's offer
so much
that if Daymond
would want to have me,
I would come in with him
just 'cause I think
what he wants to do
is so smart.
I would do it.
I love and respect Lori a lot,
but hell no.
[ Laughter ]
Wah, wah, wah.
Just 'cause this is my area,
you know what I mean?
[ Both whispering indistinctly ]
♪♪
I will go to $250,000.
Why not take more money?
But I'm gonna stay
at the 40%.
Whoa.
I really do think
you need more money.
Ooh.
Think about
what's happening here.
You're getting more offers
at higher prices, more money.
The valuation
is not as critical to me.
Greiner: Okay.
I just ‐‐ I know how much work
it's gonna be.
Would either of you
consider 25%?
No.
I went down from 40% to 33%
to be respectful
that we'll all own a third.
$125,000 for 30%.
‐$125,000 for 30%?
‐Yeah.
Okay, so you guys are at
33% and 30%.
That's really close.
Would either of you consider
a little bit more cash?
You don't need it in licensing.
That's true.
But they want to keep on doing
what they're doing.
Are you wanting to be solo?
You don't want to go in
on a deal with anyone?
I need to be a partner
with him on this
as much as
I need a hemorrhoid.
I mean...
[ Laughs ]
That doesn't sound
very pleasant, so...
See? See? Is that
the kind of partner you want?
You have two offers
on the table.
Gabe: Right.
Daymond's 33%...
33%.
...and he's giving you
the $125,000.
I didn't even play hardball.
I went from 40% to 33%.
I'm not gonna negotiate
against myself.
Robert's gone up
to $250,000 for 40%.
Make a decision.
Or $125,000 for 30%.
Right.
So, which offer
are you making?
I'm making both.
Multiple choice.
If he feels
he needs more cash ‐‐
Would you be willing
to match Robert's offer
at $125,000 for 30%?
I know the value I bring.
No.
Okay.
[ Whispering ] Do you want to
ask Daymond if he can...
♪♪
Robert, I heart you
as a human being so much.
I think you're
so genuine and kind,
but thank you.
And, yes, Daymond, we would
love to a deal with you.
‐Yeah!
[ Laughs ]
Can I hug you?
Great.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, sir.
Congrats, guys.
That's awesome.
Jessica: Thank you, guys.
I can't take it
off my hand!
Good luck, Kevin!
Good job.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God.
Jessica:
We chose Daymond because
he is really the ideal fit.
I mean, he understands
that sock industry
inside and out.
He's been wildly successful
with the sock company Bombas.
It seemed like a no‐brainer
and just a natural fit
and the perfect partner
for us.
♪♪